étrangère
[Musique]
merci
merci [
Musique] merci [
Musique]
tu ne m'aimes pas [Musique
]
tu m'as quitté bébé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étrangère
[Musique]
tu sais
tout
[Musique] [
Musique]
merci
[Musique]
étranger [Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
dis à tout le monde
[Musique]
Californie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Ouais  Ouais ouais
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
Ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais [
Applaudissements]
Refuser ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
mauvaise fille cette fille cette fille cette  fille
cette fille
[Musique]
énergie [
Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique] moi de haut
en bas [
Musique]
aujourd'hui [
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec ses chansons
étrangères
[Musique] tout
le monde tout le monde
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
pour moi ce soir
[Musique] [
Musique]
pour moi
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
étrangère [Musique
]
étrangère [
Musique] [
Musique]
traduction
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'elle a mis  cette robe c'est
Blanco, elle veut bouger, commençons
Bailando, appelle ma maman, allons Mambo si
tu veux danser, nous pourrions le faire sans
problème si l'enchère te pose des problèmes,
alors nous pouvons le résoudre, nous pouvons y aller doucement,
bébé, un pas en avant, nous pouvons le casser  baisse-toi,
enlève-le comme ça, tu n'as pas à
t'inquiéter de rien, fille, je sais exactement
ce dont tu as besoin
maman portugaise, regarde comment je mange japonais
quand tu bouges ton corps, je m'étouffe mes
genoux, secoue-le, secoue-le, secoue-le, secoue-le
comme un tremblement de terre.
[Musique]
pas de conversations,
dis ouais
[Musique]
des yeux
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
merci
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
des rires
[Musique]
dans le ticket
[  Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
dis-moi
[Musique] je
deviens fou [
Musique] [
Musique]
tu m'as rendu fou [
étrangère
[Musique] [Musique]
merci
[Musique]
êtes-vous des fleurs les gars [
Musique]
obtenez  c'est vrai
[Musique]
peux-tu me gérer comme
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
vidéos [Musique
] [Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
ok bébé
[Musique]
Big Daddy
[  Musique]
mais je jure
[Musique]